[Music]
this morning in our protecting the
planet series we're taking to the
world's longest and most grueling
competition it's called The Ocean Race
and it's a 36 000 mile adventure around
the planet on sailboats competitors
begin in Spain back in January and race
down the coast of Africa then they cut
across the Indian and southern oceans to
Brazil from Brazil they race up the
Americas and across the Atlantic to
Denmark the final leg of the race will
take the teams to Italy this week Ben
Tracy caught up with the groups during a
stop in Newport Rhode Island he
discovered the races not just about
winning but also about protecting the
oceans
you're about to feel us accelerate
Charlie and Wright is the skipper of
this 60-foot long sailboat but when he
lowers these giant fin-like hydrofoils
into the water so we're gonna hit speeds
of up to 30 miles an hour
he's more like the captain of a rocket
ship the
oh yeah
[Music]
was that we're not a camp whew
he took us out on Rhode Island's
Narragansett Bay
I'm still under against the Fate
the very same Waters where he learned to
sail as a kid do you ever think you'd be
sailing something like this through here
no when I was a kid I never get to bed
I'd sailboats it only went five six
miles an hour so for me this is a dream
come true
Enright is the leader of the 11th Hour
racing team the American entry in a
six-month 36 Thousand Mile race around
the world
his crew of five works in four hour
shifts eating sleeping and sailing at
speeds of up to 50 miles per hour
you're a sailor but also like a
survivalist a little bit you know it's
not like we have an issue out there we
can just call AAA and the main tour
massively surrendered useless alone in
the middle of the ocean they've fixed it
all from torn sales we're just gonna put
some Staples and some rip stops in it to
busted rudders
and these survivalist Sailors also have
part-time jobs on degrees now as citizen
scientists
what was your reaction when they said
yeah we want to put a bunch of
scientific instruments on your boat
great as long as everybody else is
carrying the science equation each boat
in the ocean race is outfitted with
tools to gather data on how climate
change is impacting the world's oceans
oceans are rapidly warming from
absorbing 90 percent of the excess heat
created by our planet warming greenhouse
gas emissions ocean health is critical
to human health as they provide 50
percent of the oxygen we breathe we
started the first science program within
the sailing World Lucy Hunt works on the
races science program this is their
ocean pack she showed us the equipment
on 11th Hour Racing's boat so when the
boat is going there's a continuous flow
of water through this system
high-speed Laboratories help measure
everything from sea surface temperatures
to oxygen and carbon dioxide levels they
have also detected microplastics in
nearly every sample they've taken so far
the data is distributed to Scientific
organizations all around the world and
this will actually send all of the data
off to the satellite in real time 25
000 data points per day
it's important because these boats
boldly go where few scientific missions
go
the Third Leg of the race was a grueling
38-day sale through the Wild and remote
Southern Ocean we actually passed a
place called Point Nemo which is the
farthest you can possibly be on earth
from land and the closest people to you
other than your competitors when you're
there are actually the people in the
International Space Station overhead
that just kind of boggles the mind we
are looking at the second of two Noah
Drifter buoys in the Southern Ocean they
deployed buoys provided by the U.S
government one two three
these instruments monitor surface
temperatures and ocean currents so that
then feeds weather forecasts John Hare
is a NOAA scientist he says that data
improves weather forecasting including
tracking extreme events like hurricanes
how valuable is the information they've
been collecting I truly think it is
invaluable because it's collecting
information from parts of the ocean that
we rarely have an opportunity to collect
data from standby guys charlie Enright
is focused on winning the race but his
team's name is a reminder that the clock
is also ticking in the fight against
climate change that's the important part
and that's what brings me to toy is
actually you know sinking our teeth into
it getting our hands dirty trying to
find answers to these complicated
problems for CBS mornings I'm Ben Tracy
in Newport Rhode Island
[Music]
I do like a three hour tour that's
considerably longer than a three-hour
tour but looks exciting nonetheless